schools are now shelters
people had little choice of where to go
these buildings were large and sturdy
unlike most people's homes in this
impoverished part of Pakistan
some School Grants were flooded the name
of this school is barely visible
tents have been put up to allow some
form of Education to continue
but with 17
000 schools in this province destroyed a
permanent solution is needed
we are worried about the winter coming
next month we will not be able to sit in
the towns in harsh weather conditions
but for now we are happy that we can
continue with our education with the
large number of students here we request
our government to rebuild our school so
we can continue our education
like other children sonoba lost all she
had in the floods at least 2 million
students have been affected in sin
Province alone
when flood hit our village we weren't
able to pick up anything from home we
were just able to save our lives it's
been almost one month and I'm able to go
back to school now going to a temporary
10th school but I missed the one in my
Village and my schoolmates I'm worried
how I'll be able to continue my
education in this harsh environment
more is needed and Pakistan has appealed
for international help we are
establishing dental schools and we have
requested our International Partners
International Community to provide us
School tests until now we are we we
could be able to establish 1500
temporary Learning Centers so we need to
establish 15 000 at least 15 000 more
temporary Learning Centers Villages are
cut off and people are waiting for the
waters to recede
they may have taken away lives and
livelihoods
these children are praying they don't
wash away their dreams of gaining an
education I said Big Al Jazeera